I told you like just on some yo let's
talk about this okay
can I open the cabinet a bit open it up
let's go
are you sure I'm ready Dr Drake had a
verse you heard the verse yes didn't
make the album no
but that doesn't mean it's not coming
got Tricks Up the sleeve well you did
two parts to the song you got the first
part you got to push three it might be a
four
might be a five there's a few people
that like that beat
so that Dave rap to it
um so I feel like we had a time today
where you could keep making your album
so Dr Dre was supposed to be on the on
the song
is he supposed to be on that song Or
maybe when this comes well I heard him
on that song but was it that version
I heard him on a version I feel like he
heard a different version hmm
so what's it like uh by the way did you
help him write the record no
he
he like the way Dre works is like a
collaborative thing he might take a line
or two here take certain things but he
kind of knows what he wants to say right
so it's just more so like you kind of
just like so you did you help him with
the verse no no no no okay no I didn't
know him at all with the verse I just
pulled up one day and uh actually
the verse every time I never end that
broke yes yes never end up broke
um he actually laid the verse it was him
and them joints and I came to the studio
one day and he played it
wow you know we're figuring it out
exclusively right here on the bootleg
cave show this is the first time I've
ever said this
because I got to get permission to open
the cabinet a little you know well you
know you you you're my brother so yeah
I'm all for it uh I mean I think that
like having Dre obviously co-sign is
crazy because he doesn't cosign a lot of
people that's
um how did uh that uh relationship
originally start so Dre has a nephew
who's a producer as well his name is
Keon right and I met Keon at a studio
session
he was like I'm gonna take you to meet
my uncle we ended up jumping on the
phone right
um
he was like after the Super Bowl I want
to link up with you and put some music
together Super Bowl passed about two
days later he hit me told me to pull up
to the crib I told everybody in the
studio I was going to the bathroom and I
never came back
wow so I left the studio and I went to
Dre's house and I was over there for
about four days wow just working I heard
his speakers at his house are crazy it's
Immaculate everything is like incredible
and what's so crazy is as loud as the
speakers are when you close the door to
the studio you can't hear nothing
it's just so you're just looking like
isolated oh I got you I got you it's
just like the room's just so quiet like
it's like you close the door like
imagine if we close that door like a
perfectly treated room yeah you wouldn't
hear nothing you could still like you
could if that was his studio and you
could turn the music all the way up and
close the door in the podcast what the
[ __ ] yeah and then what's crazy is he
has that same setup built in about like
two or three different Studios shout out
to Dre man the goat the goat the
greatest so how many records did y'all
do together
we have a few wow we have a record
that's really really really good
I wish she'd drop it is it on him to
drop it that one yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah it is really really good I think
it'll come out soon I think he's working
on something